love this question I will get nacho
cheese and get my popcorn in it I'm not
afraid of that
I do love a junior man Reese's Pieces I
love dr. pepper when you go to the
movies I think I don't want to get off
the ride and having to take a bathroom
break is getting off the ride I have a
bit of a paranoia about needing to pee
sense playing Captain Marvel because
it's like a 30-minute process to go the
bathroom assuming that I'm not in the
movie I want to be in the aisle center
if I'm in the movie I want to be as far
back as possible so that my head is as
small as possible on the screen I
straight up have a large popcorn and it
is always done about midway through the
second preview I agree I'm like just my
lips are chapping
not open like yes like I'm in a contest
I'm gonna win I'll get like four popcorn
sweet and salted popcorn although in the
States
it's more butter - I'm gonna like speak
to the UK and see if they can just like
ship all of their popcorn people come
middles
slightly more to us back yes I like you
I like I don't want to be like Seton
plan and that's a screen I like to sit
like here so it's like in the middle not
too far back but it can't be too far
forward oh I like to see 3/4 the way
back from the screen like in the center
but people are already sitting there you
kick him out no I don't end up in the
middle the dead middle I always go like
behind a handicap because there's
usually a bar there yeah
I like to sit on like the second row
what do you think I like and he likes to
eat popcorn and hotdog it really loves
nachos the most though I do like this in
the middle I like to eat I knew it was a
protein in it and I like to smuggle in
food I smuggling taco in-and-out burger
yes it's calmer you know me I like the
suit in the backpack
oh okay large popcorn feel better you
know like the fake butter that they pop
on there you can ask for real butter if
I'm really going for it I get M&Ms and
then put them in the popcorn so you get
that salty sweet I like to get a water
cuz I'm trying to like stay hydrated
during the film I like to sit that upper
left to me is the best it's usually
nearest exit mine is mix pop I use you
have to forget something chocolaty - oh
yeah minstrel a minstrel in the middle
of the middle
[Music]